what's that believe nation happy weekend
I thought it was time to make version
two of how to hit a million subscribers
I made my first video on this in
February at that time I had how am I
going to have it five hundred and sixty
nine thousand sky birds I'm now sitting
at six hundred and thirty nine thousand
subscribers so it's a seventy thousand
subscriber swing getting a little bit
closer to 1 million and I wanted to
share with you my journey and as well
teach you lessons that I've learned to
help you get your YouTube goals
accomplished faster last time I talked
about my channel Rosaire comments here's
a guy who are considered to be one of
the best speakers of our generation some
of the who look up to as a great speaker
someone who are considered in a way
better than me at speaking and he's
having great results in a speaking world
but I'm beating him on YouTube because
I'm playing better to the YouTube
algorithm and the lesson last time was
you need to upload frequently I was
uploading multiple times per day and he
was uploading once a week or a couple
times a week I forget exactly how much
but the frequency was way lower compared
to what I was doing and that's why I was
winning there's a direct correlation
between the number of videos that I was
posting with the growth of my channel
now you have to post good stuff you
can't post crap this guy was hoping that
people enjoy and we're really meticulous
about eliminating series that aren't
performing well and I probably get to
back in the future videos to help you
guys break down how to understand if a
series is working or not for you is how
we do it but if you're posting good
stuff when you're doing it frequently
you're going to win against people who
are just posting good stuff maybe even
better stuff very infrequently it just
is how YouTube's algorithm works you may
not agree with it you may not think it's
right but it's how it is and so paying
attention to the data can allow you to
win on YouTube where other people who
may have a lot of other advantages are
going to be second place and so did
anyone talked about me versus Gary
Vaynerchuk Gary's been a friend of the
business for a number of years I had my
first collaboration with him back in
2010 I made a line of famous
entrepreneur trading cards this is the
first page of them my favorite
entrepreneurs AP Giannini his is Vince
McMahon
and I got a quote from him on the back
quick flip to the back page you can see
this one is mine and then here's Gary
down below love Invents I've had him
interviewed on my channel we've done
some collaborations and so I want to
compare my YouTube channel to his now I
can pull up my social blade account
compare my channel to his we can't go
all the way back it's limited but I
passed his channel in September 2015 the
data that we have here shows just
beginning the year 2016 he was always
ahead of me I passed in September 2015
and I was widening the gap and what's
happened recently is Gary is closing the
gap on me he's catching up and he's
catching up in a hurry in a hurry and
why why is Gary catching up in a hurry
this is what's really true this is what
I look at I want to look at the data I
want to understand the points as Gary
gotten a lot better as a speaker not
really you know Gary is already playing
at such a high level and if you look at
what he was saying a year ago and his
delivery his enthusiasm compared to what
he's doing now it's the same level of
enthusiasm and energy and excitement
same bravado he hasn't really improved
that much as a speaker again because
he's already he was already playing at
such a high level he's been doing this
for so many years that one year to the
next is not really having a big impact
has his team gotten better yeah have
they added more production quality to it
yes has he introduced different series
yes the biggest difference maker though
is the quantity of uploads I was
crushing Gary and zoomed right past him
because I was producing way more than he
was and now he's catching up with the
quantity let me share some stats with
you
February 2016 Gary had 18 videos he
posted 18 videos in a month it's pretty
good I'm posting three a day but he's
both saying three a month in February
2016 February 2017 50 he went from 18
videos in February last year to 50
videos February this year let's start
towards the March let's
sort of March March 2016 he had 19
videos still solid 19 videos it's one
every two days just over over one over
two days right it's good quality
consistent content 19 videos March 2017
60 60 videos he goes from 19 to 60
videos he's uploading to a day or more
and that's why he's winning
he has quality content and he's playing
better to YouTube algorithm and now he's
going to patch me you look at the curve
he's catching up and he's on the path to
beat me and so I'm going to be making a
video in a couple months saying
Gary's ahead of me and I'm now not the
number one channel for entrepreneurs out
there in the world and I got out my game
it's great like it forces me to want to
play better to create better content for
you guys to add more hustle energy
because everybody else like I pass Karen
you know what does nobody else in the
field who's doing really well now the
game is on and I love it and so I really
strongly encourage you guys to look at
how often you are posting your videos
you look at Gary who was doing a good
job last year right in posting 19:18
videos a month that's pretty solid but
when he moved to Daley and when he moved
to twice a day that's when his channel
really started to explode to the point
where nobody is catching him so you want
to do that in your industry I would
definitely look at whatever your
schedule is right now and at least try
to double it I would then try to look at
how do I get to a daily schedule and
then how do I move beyond daily and it
challenges you to think how can I add
really amazing content because the value
is not there it's not going to help you
if you're just throwing up crap it's not
going to help it's got to be good
quality stuff at least once a day it's
not multiple times a day and again I'm
not saying it's right
it's just how YouTube is working and if
you play to their algorithm you have a
better chance of getting subscribers
getting notice getting your message out
and driving that into your business as
well all right next up I want to answer
some questions for you guys questions
that you'll ask on
version so if you have questions for
next time leave it down below and I'll
see what I can do first step relax and
sleep station
I enjoyed the video Evan I feel you're
very respectful when talking about Eric
Thomas and showing how regular content
is important for the algorithm hopefully
helps a lot of people get motivated to
make more content yeah this this whole
mean versus somebody has been have fun
it's a fun thing I love Eric we profiled
him a couple of times to work with his
team
Gary done collaborations with the other
people I'm going to mention in the
future of the series I have a
relationship with with as well this mad
respect I love when Eric is doing
unloved with Gary is doing it's not that
I am better than them or not it's just
showing that they could be doing better
they can be getting way better results
if they follow some of these things and
even if they don't pay attention you
could be doing better if you follow some
of these tips and strategies on your own
YouTube channel Chris to me so yes
please continue the series thank you
well this is version 2 we'll see what
happens in the coming months I'm
committed to doing it I think until I
hit a million we'll see we'll see if you
guys respond you're liking it you leave
comments you're engaging with it we'll
continue to really mom easy love this
series Evan my question is how do I make
my youtube channel more attractive
without the money to invest in things
like a better camera or channel design
initially a better camera and channel
design has a tiny impact how do you make
it better you you get better that's it
the biggest factor of my own channel is
still me if I want to go out and now
catch up the Gary who started to crush
me right I'm still out of them but he's
going to pass me - how do I beat him I
need to get better me I need to get
better my messaging should be better I
need to have more passion and to provide
more value to my audience it's me you
want to win it's not the gear it's never
the gear I'm filling this out of a
logitech webcam that I bought at best
spot you don't need to have amazing gear
you need to have an amazing message in
to provide amazing value to your
audience so stop thinking that it's your
channel art and stop thinking that's
your camera and you get better by
providing value to your audience
next up Andy jug I think I prefer to
stay behind the camera and do animation
and voice-over videos but that would
hinder my personal branding wouldn't it
do you want to build a personal
I think people connect easier to a face
to a person but it's all you want to do
is be behind the camera you might be a
little animated summary of yourself have
a little character of yourself and use
your voice that could become your brand
it's harder to connect to a cartoon
character than it is to an individual if
you came on and told your story it'd be
a lot easier but maybe building a
personal brand isn't the right way to go
for your company right you can tell your
story to this animated character you can
have a lot of success it's not about
doing it just the way that you see other
people doing it right like Eric has a
personal brand gary has a personal brand
I have a personal brand it doesn't mean
that you need to go out and build a
personal brand there's lots of people
who have one on YouTube without having
to have a personal brand and so you
forcing yourself to go out and do it
you're not going to have a lot of
success unless it's what you want like
if you want to build a personal brand
that's a deep thing that if you want to
go and do then get better at it get more
comfortable practice practice practice
practice if that's not where you want to
go and what you want to do is draw
amazing animation videos and you want to
do voiceover a narration then do that
and tell your stories through that the
impact is a personal brand won't be as
strong so yeah it will for your personal
brand but your net net value would be
much bigger because you're doing this
thing that you love instead of trying to
do somebody else urban gym how can it be
less preachy and more natural like you I
love your videos and has influenced my
channel a ton god bless just practice
gym I am NOT naturally gifted at this it
took me a lot of practice I've made
4,000 videos like you better get good at
something that you've done it four
thousand times and it's just about
developing your style practice practice
practice practice practice the quantity
will lead to the quality the more you
practice the more you get better the
more you consume - I like watching
different people's styles the way
somebody presents something I maybe pick
up a little bit and I applied in my next
video and see does that fit that doesn't
feel right if you don't like being
preachy then try not being preachy
try to find people that have given
speeches or have done something similar
to what you're trying to do in a non
preachy way if you'd like you like how I
do it you feel I'm natural it touches me
feeling natural I'm not here trying to
impress you guys I'm not here trying to
say
and better than anybody else I'm trying
to provide value I care about this
message and if you feel comfortable and
you feel natural then you'll make videos
where it's natural and comfortable and
that may mean taking a number of takes
like if you shoot the whole video until
you know what that was preaching I'm
going to do it again here's that sucked
again I'm going to do it again and the
more the more you get into it the first
time you I find at least you can at
least when I was first starting out the
first time I felt nervous and it wasn't
my best performance even now when I
start doing my videos I'll always start
doing the simple ones like the top tens
where I'm not saying much or just doing
intro extra that kind of stuff and it
gets we warmed up and revved up fuel to
do the ants Presto's and the belief
lives and the videos where I have to be
more passionate I got to be more you
know thought leadership just practice
man don't beat yourself up it's going to
come you put in the word exist in nature
it's hard to compare people jump on and
off when you're not consistent he's
screaming a lot of business for himself
offline [ __ ] in reference Eric
comments last time absolutely you know
this series is only about how to hit a
million subscribers it's not about how
to build a million dollar business it's
not about how to funnel your people
offline you know Eric Thomas is number
one goal with a million subscribers on
YouTube then his priorities would be
different and he's trying to build his
book business he's trying to build a
speaking business he's trying to build
apparel business he's got all these
paths that YouTube helps funnel but it's
not the main thing for him and so that's
fine and this is the whole point it is
hard to compare somebody who is not
consistent this is a message to you guys
I want you to be consistent if hitting a
subscriber goal is important to you in
youtube if you want to have success on
youtube then you need to be consistent
otherwise even if you're great like
Aaron Thomas people are going to hop on
and hop off and you're not going to
really build as strong a brand as you
could if you were consistent that's the
entire point of that video and this one
to Kevin Barry I like this a lot I want
to have consistent uploading but it's so
difficult balancing quality and quantity
keep this series going I hear you man
I think it's just constant
experimentation I think again the
quantity leads to the quality it's hard
to produce something that's really good
if you've never done it before so the
first time you try something it's going
to suck but the me
there's a seed there that you can use to
expand on make a little bit better next
time a little bit better next time
a little bit better next time and maybe
you have one series that just works
really well and you keep doing that and
then you experiment by adding new ones
every time for us this Saturday time
slot is always a different video we're
experimenting with four to five
different series to see which one is a
hit which one takes off that maybe we
put into our regular weekly schedule
instead of once a month and so having
some way to constantly test new series
new ideas a lot of them won't work but
if you don't test you're always going to
stay where you are
meet the constant innovation constantly
worked on the quantity to get the point
where you're making quality videos
consistently the ideas it gets of both
quantity and quality the univers guru I
do one upload on one live chat a day to
live chats account the same way in the
YouTube algorithm that's a tough one I
don't think they do as much to be honest
I don't have a lot of data to back this
up like I do for this series it's just
an intuition when Duggal lives you get
an immediate hit YouTube will email a
lot of your subscribers they'll promote
it across all your videos you get all
these people coming on to join you live
I feel like the live stuff dies down
afterwards though I don't know I feel
like it doesn't get as much promotion
does it get as much benefit it may just
be because in a live video there's a lot
of dead time and then people aren't as
engaged in watching the replay maybe
that's it maybe that's why they just
don't do as well you want to eliminate
as much fat as possible in the video and
make every second count
and then the live videos a lot of fun
stuff that's great when you're on live
but for somebody watching the replay who
wasn't part of the live audience it's
not as much fun so maybe the disconnect
so I don't know if it's a purposeful
thing that YouTube doesn't promote the
live stuff as well afterwards or if it's
just that the videos the live videos are
less engaging for for an online audience
and so it ends up being down rings but I
have definitely seen that connection
where my live videos don't do as well
ongoing as my regular videos
Alysia oh my gosh so many videos will
never watch them oh haha
that's great I made this rent video a
while ago about how I don't want you to
watch every video on my channel I don't
I don't need you to watch every video on
my channel
I'd rather that you're out producing
watch something when you need it get
inspired by it and then take some action
the point of the multiple videos per day
is really that just highlight what's
happened with the YouTube algorithm and
if you want to win you have to be
consistent I don't expect people to
watch every single video and if you
watch the people who are going on making
mass content like that quite often their
views for video will drop but net they
win because as in all of their views
their minutes watch their subscribers
they win and so if you start moving to
this model of one a day or multiple
times per day don't expect people to
watch every video don't be hurt people
don't watch the video they're watching
on their time and it's on you to provide
as much value as possible so they want
to tune in next up pair gesture on fire
I have an adult to start my own YouTube
channel I could use some of your
knowledge of how you make your videos
equipment used where you begin and
coming up with your material what
programs use to edit your videos what
inspires you in making videos and what
your thoughts are on how your videos
look now here's is the first series you
created thank you back to previous
comment if you're just so you can
channel do not get hung up on the gear
so many people get hung up on the gear
and they won't start until they have all
the gear you need the microphone I need
the camera and you need the light and
you need all this stuff doesn't matter
when I first started it was me I would
face a window so you have natural light
on you and not behind you and it just
goes to start talking hearing through
teeth your name is hairdresser on fire
so I'm assuming you're a hairdresser and
you want to share your expertise around
hairdressing that's what really needs to
come out and you can film really great
videos off of your soul with a friend
holding it or you buy a tripod and put
it up there and if you're close enough
to the phone they have a good microphone
that's enough to get started much more
important than the gear is you you can
build an amazing start by you providing
amazing value showcasing what's so
important about hairdressing I think in
terms of picking topics you gotta find
something that you actually care about
look if you're a hairdresser right now
we have a shop what's the biggest
problem that you've seen right now what
do people come in asking about what's
the biggest misconception does they're
that you want to help people with write
any business the entrepreneur is trying
to provide
I'll even help people I genuinely want
to help you guys why am I making this
video I want to help you guys anybody
was in business it's not just to make
money if you want to have success it's
the help your customers solve important
problems in their life so you want to
help people with the hair how are you
going to do that what's your message
what problems can you solve for them
what questions can you answer for them
one of the greatest ways to get start as
a thought leader
it's just think about all the questions
that you're currently getting from your
audience and then turn those into videos
that's that's how I started my channel a
lot of the early videos were me
answering questions of people who would
email in questions and instead of
entering back on email would make
YouTube video about it it was faster and
it could also potentially meet your
wider audience and just but one person
who was responding to so I would just
start start start start start start
start start get better practice get
better again
keep practicing being amazing on-camera
talent and then you can worry about the
gear and then you can worry about the
editing software then you can worry
about the bells and whistles
too many people focus on the icing and
they have no cake then the midsummer
truth speaks group question is the
better than post on YouTube or Facebook
or post on both I notice you don't post
on Facebook Facebook is really a
pay-to-play economy and that's not part
of my model there's two things that I
don't like to a Facebook one is that if
you're doing a brand page you have to
pay to get your content out you'll have
a core group of an audience who will
watch everything but to win on
Facebook's algorithm you need to pay
they have a market people willing to pay
and so that's how you win in facebook
that's how you understand the algorithm
YouTube is different and so I'm hacking
you to algorithm to build up my channel
the other thing about Facebook that I
don't really like is the content doesn't
really live forever I want it I want the
stuff that I make to live forever I want
the stuff that I made to still be
visible six years down the road 20 years
down the road I want to show my son as
it grows up I want to show my grandkids
this video that I make it for you guys
and the heart and energy and passionate
Evan Carmichael hiring in 2017 I want
them to see that I want the stuff I make
people are still watching videos that I
made five years ago or more I like that
I want to feel like every piece of
content I make is going to
forever has the ability to do so and
Facebook sure you can go back the post
don't get deleted like they would on
snapchat but you don't really go back on
a Facebook post from five years ago you
don't go back and visit posting two days
ago and so I don't like that I don't
like that that's that rush so I think
with Facebook if you had equal sized
audiences on both you'll get more
instant views on Facebook especially if
you do any kind of boosts around it to
your audience but you'll get way longer
term impact if you're on YouTube and so
that's that's the game I don't care
about hitting everybody tomorrow but I
want people to be changed and when I'm
in this for the long run and so YouTube
is a better place yl mompreneurs has
just been 100% organic growth or have
you used sponsored post ads in the mix
as well it's ninety-nine point seven
percent organic growth we've done some
targeted ads based around certain videos
to help give them a little more exposure
but from my experience in every campaign
that I've run you can get views from
advertising but you can't get
subscribers subscribers don't convert a
lot from the views on videos at least
from my experience and every ad that
I've run and so we don't make that a
priority it is one of you that we're
just trying to get some awareness I help
the branding something like that then
then we may run a couple campaigns but
in terms of driving subscriber growth
it's almost zero which sucks but if you
do the work on the organic side you make
really good stuff that people want to
share where they watch the video and
like that was amazing I'm going to
subscribe the channel and tell my
friends about it then you can get the
growth so almost a hundred percent of my
growth has been just from organic and
doing things like this of understanding
YouTube's algorithm to get as much
exposure as possible pump iron is asking
Evan I love your videos my question is
how do I make money on YouTube that may
be a future video I don't know we'll see
if I cover that on on a standalone I've
done this already on my channel besides
I think the way to get started is
initially if you're just enough of the
youtuber you make a little bit of money
off of the Adsense that comes in the key
though that you're making more money
will come when you have an audience and
people start paying attention
you so I started getting my first brand
deals the first brand deal I think I had
around 40,000 subscribers somewhere
around there where I started to get on
company's radar where they wanted to
hire me to do stuff get involved with me
send me products hire me for things and
so when you start to build an audience
then you'll start getting more
opportunities I got my book deal mostly
because I have a youtube audience I get
offers to join companies boards of
directors because of my YouTube audience
things I've never thought of I never
started my huge job trying to get
Brandon eels or book deals or joining
companies boards or invested into
businesses was never part of the plan
but it happened because I built an
audience and so there's a painful point
at the start where you're doing it
because I just any business by the way
like when you're starting is painful to
start you're doing it for the love and
the joy there's no company we just start
you're instantly successful there's a
lot of heartache and pain and blood and
sweat and worked on the quantity to get
to the quality right that then leads to
you having opportunities if you sell an
offline product so you know Turner then
salsa YouTube is not our main focus but
when we make youtube videos that helps
promote an offline business like looking
at Eric Thomas who became YouTube famous
and he turned that into offline
businesses offline revenue streams
seminars and conferences and speaking
gigs and I don't think does coaching
apparel you know book turn it into
offline business and doesn't focus as
much on YouTube
so other people have past when a YouTube
front but it's okay for him because he
is making money elsewhere and so there's
a lot of different paths but at the
start if you haven't started you just
use on your way I won't even worry about
monetizing if just making money is your
goal do something else because it's
going to take a long time to get there
you got to do the videos 250 logo kyle
done how important is production quality
of a video like editing music
transitions kind of talked about it it's
important but sorry christina editing
this video it's important but it's you
you can have the best editing in the
world but if your message sucks and you
suck on camera it's not going to save
you you would get way better results as
you doing it and so don't let those
things hold you back get started improve
your message get better practice
practice practice practice practice make
a good video
Anthony Lazzaro I think the
million-dollar question is how do you
choose the topics with Google Trends
video i don't use google trends my name
is google trends at all most of the
topics come from what you guys are
asking for so when I'm doing a top 10
when I'm doing believe life and I'm
doing mentor me there they come from
what you guys have been asking for
what's already popular in the channel
our top 10 for example we have 3,000 ish
requests for top 10 to do we look at
what the most popular ones are so what
are the names that have been put up
who's been mentioned the most and then
we start looking can we get enough
content on them some you know there's
not enough content to can't do it but
that's how it ticket and the topics for
other videos are usually based on what
you guys are asking for or something
that I just I want to make this series I
wanted to make a video on it nobody
saying hey making video series on how to
make get a million subscribers I just
wanted to do it this is that combination
what the audience is asking for plus
what I'm doing we don't look at Google
Trends and saying hey what's happening
right now and let's try to let's try to
just ride this wave out it's definitely
a model and and maybe that's a blind
spot for us it's just not how we've
achieved our growth alright I think I'm
going to end it there guys tons of
questions came in there's still a lot
more to get to but I'm seeing some
repeat ones come in so if you have a
question you want me to answer in the
next edition of this series leave it
down the comments below if you see
questions you like give them a thumbs up
so I'll see them first when I'm making
the video next time and if you want this
series to continue leave it down below
as well thank you guys for the love
thank you for joining me on my journey
to hit a million subscribers and
hopefully as I teach you in the process
you get strategies to apply to your own
channel to help you achieve your goals
as well whether it's hitting a million
hundred thousand ten thousand thousand
ten million whatever your subscriber
goal is hopefully the series is helping
you I also want to give a quick shout
out to placer thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and sharing it on Twitter
really really means a lot to me I hope
you're enjoying the reason getting value
from it so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I would
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is what's
love I'll see see
you